20 consecutive middleweight title
defenses by this man and coming up in a
couple of Saturdays at Madison Square
Garden he will put it all on the line
against Steve rolls he is triple G good
to see you sir - see - and this kicks
off your your your friendship
partnership with the zone correct
correct yeah exactly what where did the
ozone relationship come from triple G
walk me through how this happened cuz a
bunch of people you know we're like
where wow this is quite a deal that you
you got put together how did this all
come about for you is awesome right now
it's completely different situation for
sport for boxing special for boxing
thank you the zone you know he's he give
a lot of appointments like a lot of like
points to people Halawa spar
of course I have a like deal good deal
yeah I would say so
I'm very enjoying my time with the
zoning on chess I'm very happy
what's that's great what do you expect
out of rolls here and what should we
expect out of this fight you versus
Steve he's 19 and no 10 knockouts what
type of fight do you expect from him Rob
yeah first of all he may be he's not big
name and I believe he's a very good
fighter because I understand his
position right now you know I remember
my situation like him you know
I'm undefeated nobody beat me you know
nobody knows how to beat me you know and
he's very hungry and first of all his
professional outlets his professional
boxer is very dangerous
this is not game this serious business
mm-hmm so you are expecting to go long
into the night with him or nobody no
this is boxing hey no of course I want
course I want I want to bring like big
IFS big you know emotional for my fans
for boxing fans mmm-hmm
and right now you're currently in Big
Bear with your new trainer correct
Jonathan banks exactly what what what
this your first fight with him why did
you decide to part ways with your with
your previous trainer enable dimensions
different it's different you know thank
you Jonathan hey he'll bring a lot of
ideas you know like I like him he's like
old school he he's called Emma mustard
everybody knows who this gentleman you
know just I need this guy and he need
this his experience and right now
bugging for me like I know like a second
sport you know just I'm open he opened
my eyes for different level you know
just I feel different
so you feel different I feel hot pretend
you feel like how so I feel like a
student you know like a teenager
you know he brings me like couple points
just doesn't know just okay I feel my
style us I feel my stuff and he bring
more a lot that's all is amazing okay
cuz I mean you know I don't know how
many people would be watching you and
saying you know what I think he needs a
little bit of this a little bit of any
extra it's just I don't know what could
possibly be added to your your game
trilogy I mean so what do you think you
know I believe these big bones for my
fans like a ball of because my speed is
different my you know feeling my timing
is different you know and I hate I
believe will bring amazing shots on June
8th ok June 18 I'm Addison square garden
it's you versus Steve rolls of and it's
kicks off the six fight three year
global partnership between your
promotions triple G promotions into zone
you smile every single time I might try
to do okay because I'm happy
this is my second life your second life
yeah exactly
what why did you is it true you got
started in fighting at age 10 in
Kazakhstan that is trench story why why
how did you get yeah this long time ago
just nobody just I play a soccer and
basketball
I remember my oldest brother he said
okay Jay maybe you try boxing I said no
this is not interesting for me she said
try maybe you know like summer camp
going to boxing club right we're coming
to boxing club everybody play basketball
and soccer
it's very enjoying all like some month I
would say play basketball
and I remember like tambour my coach my
first course said a hey guys maybe we'll
try boxing why not because we know
everybody and why not
mm-hmm it's I don't know how just I'm
staying for this time do you remember
whose ass you first kicked it was their
10 year old kid in Kazakhstan that you
really took care of do you remember that
I don't remember really just I remember
like every day we have a fight you know
just you know like everything every day
is changed so many people's come like
real fighters real like ain't no
warriors like a street fighters you know
just ok I understand I need protect you
know he's like ok I know this guy I know
this guy
it's a different guy and it learn more
because I need protect and and now
obviously what you have become has been
something else but how how did you get
discovered I mean how did you who is the
one who's like ok this is a guy that
needs to be on a major international
stage yeah is like a step by step you
know just before we staying in the
national team before World Cup okay and
just my corset okay so have a big chance
for World Cup we're going to walk up
with bit coral cup I'm gold medalist and
before the impacts people said okay just
Olympic game we're going to Athens 2004
mmm you know after after Athens after
Olympic Games I have a silver medal yes
I am asked my coaches said okay coaches
you know my dream just I watch a lot of
fights
I want to try professional style he said
okay maybe you're not so old you know
like 22 years old right try why not
I try and it's worked this time I stay
here triple G here on the Rich Eisen see
a few more minutes left with him okay so
if you were when you
although put it this way Steve rolls you
beat him what about a third fight with
Canelo Alvarez triple G I want I want
everybody won
just everybody just so many people asked
me AG I want said yeah of course because
you know I understand this is first of
all this business this is deal with the
zone
this is businesses a lot of money it is
like how are like questions I have a
questions he have a questions in others
it's not finished
probably instance in September if of
course like my focus Harper sent to
stiffen I understand that and if I don't
have problem I'm ready is he ready of
course he is ready he's I believe he's
giving you an indication that this would
I mean let's put it this way
I'm sure he thinks he deserved what he
got
yeah do you think you won those fights
he want I know he's promotion like he'll
we play like you know and everybody and
this is a good deal for business but do
you think you won those two fights
against Canelo Alvarez triple chairlift
yes of course
no I no I I would think you'd say that
but I felt like I just had to pull that
out of you everybody knows just
everybody wants and we're ready
why not amazing side for us and you know
September and he's probably look biggest
day and like Independence Mexican day
why not
did you see earlier this month against
Daniel Jacobs did you see that I saw
okay
good fight it's good fight and a little
bit just you know I know Daniel Jacobs
Daniel and I'll canal oh you were there
yeah Vegas just for me just I want more
just because normally these two guys
like different level and he stay like a
like a sparring you know like it too not
interesting
I like war I like drama show you know
just these guys know show me it's gonna
all the toughest guy you thought ever
yeah Harper Sam that includes the bear
you for special you know he's young you
know he's young and every fighters
different I respect all fighters spring
just everybody is different and Canelo
right now he's like and
he's big he's career and probably he's
best
okay so a win against Steve rolls June
8th yeah Madison Square Garden kicks off
your dues own relationship with triple G
productions
then comes getting down to business here
with Canelo Alvarez and you think
something like that can happen by
September absolutely thing absolutely
it's possible where would you want the
fight to take place I give you I wave
the wand it's your it's your world we're
paying rent you want g productions with
the zone where where does that fight
take place if you could make it happen
I like whole school like I'm a call box
informational square garden you know he
said law in Nevada
you know like Vegas we have maybe Dallas
maybe AT&T Stadium why not Jay Jones he
loved it box is huge for us and I don't
know this business side no I'm a boxer
I'm ready I want that's it ok well this
is the AT&T Studios of the Rich Eisen
show ok yeah we could you know clear out
some space here I mean and we could do
it I mean right in the middle here I
think we could move back you know Mike
you could spar with him right today not
use the phrase from beginner Thrones
not today today very good all right this
is fun man thanks for coming on here
thank you so much oh gee you bet it at
triple G boxing on both Twitter and
Instagram before you fight Canelo
Alvarez come back here about that I
broke how about that view there you go
thank you and you don't break a promise
right Madison Square Garden Saturday
June 8th 12 rounds triple G versus Steve
rolls it's all part of the again new
relationship between triple G promotions
into zone which is the world's fastest
growing sports streaming platform for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app